Continuing in Al-Wajeez,
and we have reached the
chapter of Adab al-Khala, the etiquettes
of relieving oneself.
We've mentioned
what the author has told us this far,
and that is that
it is
preferable, it is encouraged that
before a person enters
the which would be in our case the
restroom or the place where the person
is going to
relieve himself,
is to say Bismillah, Allahumma inni
audhu bika min al-khubthi
wal-khabaith aw al-khubthi wal-khabaith.
And that when a person
leaves, they are to say Ghufraanak.
And in this process, a person is to
enter with the left foot and leave with
the right foot.
[Arabic recitation]
to relieve himself
it is preferable that the person choose
a place
either distant enough or concealing
enough that his
his entire body is no longer observable.
This is part of the perfection of the
Muslim's character
and the Muslim's haba and the Muslim's
and that is that a person has dignity.
And to perfect the Muslim's dignity
it is obligatory that when a person
relieves himself his private parts are
concealed from the eyes of onlookers at
all times.
And it is preferred that a person choose
a place where even his body
is not observable.
Why? What's the point of Well,
just the image of a person's body, the
silhouette, the outline of a person
relieving himself
is something which is
disliked
by Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. They
should be in a position where even their
even their body is
concealed and not even their
posture can be observed.
And this goes on into modern times.
Right? Is it permissible to use a
urinal? A urinal?
No. As long as a person doesn't
you know, get
get himself
as long as a person doesn't have the
urine come back on them and and and soil
a person's clothing or a person's
body, sure.
But is that mus- is that
makruh? Disliked? Yes. Why? Because the
person's body is observable while he is
relieving himself.
And the Prophet sallallahu alayhi wa
sallam, he would always choose a place
where even his body is hidden from the
eyes of onlookers when he is relieving
[Arabic recitation]
Jabir radiyallahu anhu, and here he
cites a narration, he says, "We went
with the Messenger of Allah sallallahu
alayhi wa sallam on a journey, and the
Messenger of Allah sallallahu alayhi wa
sallam's habit was that he would not go
to relieve himself until he would find a
place that would conceal the entirety of
his body as he was relieving himself."
All of his body is concealed from the
eyes of onlookers.
Now, is this in every single instance
that the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam
relieved himself? No.
There are a handful of incidents
where
some of the companions radiya'llahu
'anhu relate to us
the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam's
posture
while he was relieving himself. They
could only know this by seeing it.
But, this was either to teach
or because there was no
place in the immediate vicinity that
would that would, you know,
that would provide him with that total
concealment, right?
Again, this is part of the
high
levels of dignity
that the hu- that that the Muslim
is taught by the Prophet Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam.
You know, you notice in in in modern
culture, if you want to call it culture,
modern debauchery,
you notice that
it's almost
casual, normal
for
husbands and wives
to be using the restroom in front of
each other and breaking wind in front of
each other and belching in front of each
other and right?
this is less so
in the Arab culture for wives in
front of their husbands.
This is largely a cultural thing in
America
and in the West. This is totally normal.
And a husband in front of his wife that
he would pass gas in front of his wife,
that he would
you know, use the bathroom in front of
her, that he would
do things this.
Absolutely the opposite of what the
prophet salallahu alayhi wasallam was
doing.
And then the the ideas well this
is who I am, this is me. And my husband
or my wife needs to love me for who I
am. What a silly
ridiculous
statement. What does that mean, who I
am? You don't have any privacy? You
don't have anything you're ashamed of?
You don't have anything that makes you
shy? Nothing? Who I am? Not everybody
needs to be watching who you are, right?
Some things need to be hidden.
Discretion.
The better part of valor, discretion the
better part of dignity.
A person is is dignified. Be married for
20 years, 30 years, 40 years.
The companions radi allahu anhu, the
prophet salallahu alayhi wasallam, none
of their wives have ever seen them pass
gas in front of them. Never seen them
relieve themselves in front of them.
Things that. Dignity, right? This
maintains that level of dignity and it
becomes twice fold for the wife in front
of her husband.
We to say that they're the same,
they're not the same. A woman's
dignity is
and attractiveness is far more fragile.
Especially in front of her husband,
especially in front of
that she must protect her modesty,
protect her and never be associated in
her husband's mind with vulgarity, with
foul smells, with laziness, with things
that, right? This is incredibly
important
in order to maintain that
constant level of dignity that is
between the husband and the wife and
that level of
respect
that is between the husband and the
wife. There are things that absolutely
no human being should ever see of you.
Relieving yourself, exposing yourself,
you know, certain thoughts, certain
behaviors, certain certain actions.
These are things that
the prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
teaches us
of how to perfect our dignity and for
men al-haybah
that a man has a strong presence, not an
almost teetering on intimidating
presence, a presence that
demands respect, right? This is very
important. This is something that the
prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
taught the companions radiyallahu anhu.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah rabbil alameen.